[Music]
by now we are well-acquainted with the
idea of differentiation and integration
we know that the derivative of a
function tells us its instantaneous rate
of change and the integral of a function
tells us the area under its graph we can
see that these two ideas were developed
to tackle two different kinds of
problems but it turns out that these
ideas are related to each other in this
video we will see how the process of
differentiation and integration are
opposite to each other but wait there's
more this relation has one major
advantage for us we have seen earlier
how to find the integral of a function
first we divide the area into rectangles
then we find the sum of the areas of the
rectangles then to get the area under
the graph we take the limit of the sum
of the areas as the width of the
rectangles tends to zero we can see that
this process is a bit lengthy and
cumbersome we can't do this every time
so now we will see that this relation
comes to our rescue
it gives us an easier way of finding the
integral of the function so let's get
started consider a car traveling on a
road we know that the distance traveled
by the car and its speed a port
functions of time let's denote the
distance traveled with variable Y and
the speed with s and the time elapsed
with T now suppose the distance
travelled by the car is this function of
time it's the square of t can you tell
me what will be the speed of the car at
any instant T we know that the speed at
an instant T is the instantaneous rate
of change of the distance traveled so it
will be equal to the derivative of the
distance function at the instant T and
we have seen earlier that the derivative
of this function is equal to 2t
see so this function will give us the
speed of the car at time T its graph
will look like this now to see the
relation between differentiation and
integration consider this integral of
the speed function here t1 is some
arbitrary time instant let's mark it
here on this axis can you find the value
of this integral for this we need to
find this area under the graph but since
this is a triangle we don't even have to
use integration here notice that at t1
the value of this function is equal to
two times t1 so the base of this
triangle will be equal to t1 and its
height will be equal to two times t1 so
the area of this triangle will be equal
to t1 squared so we get that this
integral from 0 to t1 is equal to t1
squared but notice that according to
this distance function T 1 squared is
exactly the distance traveled in time t1
so what does this tell us we see that
the area under this graph tells us the
distance travelled by the car since t1
is an arbitrary value of time T this is
true for any time instant T so this
integral is the function of time this is
the connection between integration and
differentiation we have a function f of
T and it's differentiation gives us this
function f prime of T now integration of
this derived function gives us the
function f of T back so we see that the
process of integration and
differentiation act opposite to each
other integration is the reverse of
differentiation and differentiation is
the reverse of integration if you
remember we mentioned earlier that this
relation can be used to find the
integral of the function easily
can you think of how we can use the
following relation for this let's see
that in the next part
now we understand that the process of
integration is actually the reverse of
differentiation if we take the integral
of the derivative of the function f of T
we get back the function f of T take a
moment and understand this observe this
integral it tells us that for each value
of T 1 this integral will be equal to
the value of the function f of T at T 1
for an arbitrary time T 1 it's equal to
this area under the graph now let's see
how this relation helps us in finding an
integral of a function consider this
integral of the function 2t between T
equal to a and B here a and B are just
some constant numbers let's say they are
these numbers on the T axis so this
integral will be equal to this area
under the graph now can you tell me what
will be the value of this integral
notice that this area is equal to the
difference in the areas between this
triangle and this one yes the big
triangle minus the small one we know
that the area of this big triangle is
equal to this integral from 0 to B and
the area of this triangle is equal to
this integral from 0 to a but now
according to this we don't have to find
the value of these integrals notice
these integrals will be equal to this
integral for t 1 equal to a and b so we
get the value of this integral is equal
to f of B minus F of a what will this be
equal to now yes B squared minus a
squared so we see that using the
function f of T we can easily find any
integral of the function f prime of T
any integral of the derivative of the
function will be equal to the difference
in the value of the function evaluated
at the limits of integration
this result is true in general and it's
called the fundamental theorem of
calculus now we can use this result to
find the integral of a function let's
see how so we know the fundamental
theorem of calculus now consider this
function G of X equal to x squared let's
say we want to find the integral of this
function from A to B can you tell me how
we can use this result to find this
integral suppose we find a function
capital G of X such that its derivative
is equal to the function G of X since we
get that the derivative of capital G of
X is equal to G of X we can see that the
integral of this function will be equal
to this integral now notice that we can
apply this result here we will get the
integral of G of X to be equal to
capital G of B minus capital G of a so
we can see that we just have to find the
function capital G of X this function is
such that it's derivative is equal to G
of X can you find this function share
your thoughts in the comment section
below
such a function capital G of X is called
the antiderivative or the indefinite
integral of the function G of X in the
next video we will see what this means
and also find this function capital G of
X to stay updated do subscribe to our
Channel
[Music]